setting goals with your kids and doing
it right Kirsten Joyce speaks to one
woman who's sharing some tips on how
parents and kids should come together
and make those New Year's resolutions
succeed
I have training in everything from Child
Development to interpersonal
neurobiology trauma recovery mom Sarah
Moore is the founder of dandelion seeds
positive parenting where she shares
Vlogs to help other parents number one
listen more than you talk her biggest
piece of advice when setting goals
together with your children listen to
them one of the quickest ways to get
kids to tune out is if we start telling
them what their goals should be nobody
likes hearing the should word right so
if we start paying attention to what's
important to our children what they want
to accomplish and how we can support in
them and what's meaningful to them they
are much more likely to interact with us
and care about the outcome be cautious
to assume that your child will
prioritize a goal the same way we would
and when we see a goal isn't working
don't make the following mistake it's
really common that the parent instead
kind of lays down the law and says well
you agree and whatever but all that does
is make our kids shut down more so if we
can meet them where they are and figure
out how can we have peace and support
together maybe we co-create the goal and
follow through together rather than
independently you'll have a child who
feels better about it
her tip for you is lead by example if
your children see that you're working
hard to achieve your New Year's
resolutions they might just do the same